Boosh male small plates casual chic
ambience no free soda refills
jakey's coming on a date are you going
on a date with Amy what's know why
because you guys just kissed in my
mission Charles we just kissed cuz we
were undercover that's it yeah it didn't
mean anything
not that it's any of your business Boyle
but the person that I'm taking on a date
is a girl from the gym what why is this
the first time I'm hearing about her or
that you go to the gym Jake avoid the
weights nobody wants you turning into
another Terry look hey people like the
way that I look sure they do big guy
look I can't believe you're gonna take
some Fitness floozy to bouche lingerie
should be going with Amy right Amy uh
whatever dawg date the flooze
see it's never gonna happen Boyle okay
because I find Amy repulsive and she
finds me extremely handsome
so stop pressuring us oh you sweet naive
boy I haven't even begun to pressure you
to I've already written my best man
speech for your wedding
[Music]
so how is the restaurant such a normal
time are you being weird Amy and I
kissed
what to keep our cover from being blown
we didn't have a choice
Charlie hey Charles it was just a kiss
okay it was for work it was nothing yeah
who cares about a kiss call me if you
grab each other's asses he's pulling
over what's going down
you guys are so naive it's never nothing
in high school I played Daddy Warbucks
in Annie Becca murse played Annie we
were supposed to hug onstage at first
that seemed like nothing to if I opening
night we were full-on making out as
Daddy Warbucks in Annie mm-hmm the
audience was not on board
playwrights through the school guys guys
it's not a handoff he's leaving a
package
okay you and Rosa follow Augustine right
and you and Amy follow your hearts no
we're gonna stay with the package and
each other forever come on no no no no
can we please just go to dinner oh no no
no no this is not how you and Amy are
supposed to end you're supposed to grow
old and die holding each other as your
cruise ships slowly takes on water what
do want me to say we tried really hard
we made rules we kept it light and
breezy light and breezy Oh Clayton
Breezies how you describe a linen
pantsuit not a relationship you care
about we were just being cautious
cautious oh you guys started this with
one foot out the door
that's what doomed you not the universe
actually makes a lot of sense I was
agreeing with you I'm sorry I'm just so
excited about all this all right so what
do I do
tell me easy you march over there you
tell her how you feel and you're
bringing a fancy bottle of lavender
shampoo because shampooing a woman's
head is the most erotic thing you could
ever know no no shampoo that's the worst
but I am gonna go over there I want to
tell her how I feel yeah go get her No
wait till starts raining now that's
crazy go now okay okay I was home and I
really want to talk to someone about us
and dozerman and about hope being gone
and then I realized that the only person
I want to talk about that stuff with is
you so screw just being colleagues and
screw light and breezy great
definitely guys we did it I really did
it Oh Charles is here
Rick died listen guys Jake and I were
talking last night no chuckle art set
the scene spooning or face-to-face
Charles anyway we came up with a plan
Jake is going to befriend the vulture so
he lays off of us it's true I'm gonna
bro down with him if everything goes
according to plan we should be beer pong
doubles partners by the end of the week
no I'm just tired I didn't ask for part
two never fear Amy for I have the
solution to all of your problems highly
potent liquid speed oh you're gonna love
best of Devon we're cops read the room
but I know you'll be excited because I
busted Devon here with four vials of
this which is a new drug called taxi you
actually found some yep your CI was
right it's popping up on the corners
yeah my snitches are the best the key is
to always send them a handwritten
thank-you notes no so what do you say
shall we take this partnership from the
sheets to the streets Oh our first case
is a couple why not hey guys I just
discovered new truck - it's called your
relationship and I'm lying on it
try as I'm gonna need you to back off
man Roger that her perps name is Carl
obey my CI said he's selling counterfeit
caviar out of a blue stall this place
smells like a squid farted inside a
whale's but yes that is the exact combo
of smells nicely done
hey next week is my six-month
anniversary with Amy should I do
something special you know what I like
about our relationship Jake we don't
talk about our love lives or our
families or anything that's on our minds
it's why you're my closest friend of the
world yeah I know but I need help on
this I asked Boyle and he was useless
what a baby here Jake what are you
waiting for
no we're gonna buy it I mean do I look
pregnant I mean I guess I can see it I
think it's amazing
Oh Jake and Amy and baby makes three I
don't know if I believe in God but I
have prayed for this that is psychotic
look at whatever one chance
so Charles and I really got into it on
the plane
and around Sunday number five I realized
we should move in together you and
Charles no you and me
oh yes that makes so much more sense
absolutely immediately let's do that I
love you so much I love you so much too
I love this so much
so I guess Charles was listening to our
conversation yeah yeah Boop I'm gonna
get this hey I never really got a chance
to say hi yeah hi oh my god everyone
Jake and Amy are going to kiss for the
first time in six months
let those Nicolas sparks fly so
everyone's just gonna watch us yes now
get to it you lovebirds here we go come
on how did you get there so fast
Love Finds away so I know you're Jake's
best friend let me say that did you get
that on tape no no I didn't say that no
you didn't get on tape it doesn't matter
either way you screwed up big time
anyway all I'm saying is I know you're
Jake's best friend and you really want
him to win this bed are you kidding
that's the last thing I want Jake moving
in with you is my dream come true your
apartment is two blocks away from mine
Jake will be able to pop by anytime
imagine it he's had a tough day he's
fighting with Amy you know how you let
things escalate so just walks over to my
place bottle of wine and hand
oh just talk it out and then by the time
that bottles finished you come to your
senses and apologize
maybe I don't want to win this bet I
love these thermal goggles Amy listen to
me very carefully if you and Jake are
thinking of trying you are ovulating
like crazy right now you take that
helmet off before I knock it off what
your basal temperature is off the charts
this is a good thing the auditor will
start by joining Peralta and Santiago on
their gang stakeout because here and
there his dream couple you need to calm
down we're in a workplace I can't pick
him up coz she's out of town with Ava
and the sitter doesn't get to my house
till 6:30 Jake and I can pick them up
absolutely a couple of issues I don't
have any car seats and my rear window is
technically a shower curtain really why
you know what doesn't matter just take
my minivan
you got it thanks guys I appreciate it
[Music]
why are you doing that with your face
I'm smiling at mommy and daddy gross
picking up the Cagney and Lacey one
taste of practice parenting and you two
will be so hot to have sex the kind of
make babies
walk away Charles okay but Deb be back
in nine months how ridiculous is Charles
so ridiculous maybe you should go talk
to him about it you know go to his house
yeah that's a good idea I'm gonna do
that and while you're talking to him
Jake and Amy can babysit your kids
unless you're too busy making babies
over there I don't trigger Berger now
I'm gonna get out of us but also their
little shoes are so cute there are like
little circles I know and everything
they hold looks so big because their
hands are so tiny yeah and they have to
hold a cup of water with both hands cuz
they're so we talking about lucky for
you Amy I'm an unlicensed doula I've
delivered three of my cousins and one of
my uncles long story oh oh wait Jake and
me are getting married tonight titled my
sex ain't was yeah I gotta look for that
work what give it up Wow
[Music]
Wow you look beautiful
thank you this dress is incredible Gina
this would have been so crazy if you
wore this to our wedding
hey Amy I knew I ruined your veil but I
made you a new one it's a shower curtain
ah yep
Terry bumble to task but we got your
bouquet wow that's gorgeous
thank you where did those come from at
least you found a florist in the city
that was still open and picked him up
huh all right keep it in your pants okay
here we go Jake
Amy let's go downstairs it's wedding
time so here it is I really hope you
like it but if you don't I will kill
myself
Charles it looks amazing it's beautiful
how can I ever repay you get pregnant
use your body to give the world more
Jade Jolie crap all right I'm gonna take
Charles away from you now I will see you
left
you